cuál es la situación actual de los
agricultores en el país y qué medidas le
piden al gobierno
la situación actual en estos momentos es
de una gran incertidumbre por parte del
sector agropecuario
lo que estamos
solicitándoles al gobierno claramente es
un cambio de rumbo y que vea al sector
agropecuario como un pilar pilar de
desarrollo y crecimiento en el país que
hace falta y no solamente como una
fuente de recursos fiscales cuando los
gobiernos han necesitado recaudar
siempre han recurrido al sector
agropecuario eso ha ido deteriorando la
rentabilidad y generando un escenario
que ha ido cada vez peor en detrimento
de la producción y de esa forma yendo
con marcha atrás en lo que es el
crecimiento del sector agropecuario hay
varios puntos como el doble mercado
cambiario la carga impositiva por exceso
de los derechos de exportación y hoy
estamos afrontando la falta de insumos
de combustibles y de insumos importados
agrava mucho más el escenario que
estamos viviendo con las complicaciones
para que el campo pueda estar creciendo
en el argentino está hablando usted de
complicaciones para el campo en
argentina sin embargo con la escasez de
grano y otras materias provenientes de
ucrania también de rusia no debería
argentina a verse beneficiada como
productora
si efectivamente el precio en alza de
los commodities a nivel internacional
lamentablemente por un conflicto bélico
favorece de alguna manera los ingresos
de las exportaciones en argentina pero
sin duda con la carga impositiva que
existe a través del gobierno argentino
hace que de cada 100 pesos que se
exporte 70 pesos queden en manos del
estado por cargas impositivas y derechos
de exportación con lo cual el productor
solamente recibe 30 por ciento de lo que
se exporta y esto no le alcanza nos
genera un nivel de rentabilidad como
para que se vea reflejado esta situación
externa esta situación de precios de los
productos exportables que realmente hoy
tienen un precio muy interesante con lo
cual estamos diciendo que argentina está
desperdiciando una oportunidad ya que
tiene ventajas competitivas si no
tuviera esta excesiva
esta excesiva carga de impuestos
tendrían ventajas competitivas con lo
cual podría estar claramente
mejorando su posición y no teniendo que
reclamar ante los gobiernos de turno